*sniff-sniff*
Technology has become predominant over everyone's lives in the past 20 years
People now have smartphones and Smart TV's
Everything is smart. With people having a cellphone on them 24/7
It's impossible to not check your social media sites and see what your friends, classmates or family are up to, and we love it
Staying in touch is so much easier now, and with just a click of a button
We can see cute animal pictures, recipe videos and every photo our best friends have ever posted
But with that great power comes great responsibility
And sometimes it can even cause anxiety
Let's be clear. It's not the actual sites that can cause that anxious feeling. It's the addiction to checking the site
I mean, I can put my phone down whenever, right? But wait, I just want to see who that new girl
Erin is dating now. Ohh! Look at that yummy recipe video, and *oh my goodness!* another cute dog
It's hard not to get sucked into the social media sinkhole
It's so easy to say to ourselves
"One more scroll", while putting off responsibilities like homework, walking your not Instagram-famous dog and
Doing the dishes
Unfortunately, the more you let yourself scroll, the harder it is to get back out
When you're finally in a situation where you can't check or update social media like when you forget your phone
Or you're in an important lesson, you feel anxious
You keep thinking about checking what everyone's up to and you can't stop reaching for your smart device that may or may not even be there
That's what we mean by Social media anxiety
It's almost like an addiction
Compulsively checking for updates can cause unnecessary anxiety in your life
Which takes away all the fun of social media. If you aren't sure whether you've
Experienced social media anxiety or not here are some ways to know: Do you compulsively check social media every few minutes?
Do you feel anxious or nervous if you aren't able to check it?
When having a real-life conversation with someone, are you scrolling through social media?
If you said yes to any of those, you might be experiencing more anxiety than you need to be
Luckily there are some ways to get rid of it
Instead of compulsively or habitually reaching for your phone make it a conscious choice
By saying to yourself: "I am going to check my social media". Then you are staying in control of the scroll
Keep your phone in your pocket if you're having a face-to-face conversation with someone, unless you're showing each other cool vacation photos
This is another way to exert control on your social media scrolling by not splitting your attention as you do it
Remind yourself that there will just be more to look through if you don't have access to your social media for a while
This turns any anxiety you might feel into excitement and will let you get back to focusing on the task at hand
Social Media is a great resource to use to communicate with friends and family
It's always nice to see pictures from someone's trip and I'm positive everyone would like to see a picture of your adorable pet
I love social Media, but I don't like the anxiety that can come with it
We hope that by integrating these tips your social media experience stays fun forever
We can't wait to see more cute pictures of your pet
Don't forget to comment and subscribe below, so you can stay up to date when you do jump on Social Media